[Music]
a quick reminder before we get into
today's episode we now have a 2024
microcosmos calendar available it
features images from 12 of our most
popular Journey to the microcosmos
videos and you can get yours now at
microcosmos do
store we're going to do something we
don't usually do on this channel we're
going to play a clip in
reverse if you were to describe what
you're seeing you might say something
like it looks like someone dropped a
bowl of rice on the ground or maybe
you'd come up with something more
eloquent something that captures the
array of gray and green and maybe even
faint bits of purple but as we'll see in
a bit there's something kind of funny
going on with this group in fact let's
call that the theme for today a bunch of
funny things going on in the microcosmos
[Music]
we're going to return to this footage
throughout our video today but we'll
also be visiting some of the other
unusual finds that James our master of
microscopes has made recently and when
we do return to this scene just remember
that we're playing it in reverse for now
let's just take a second to describe
some of what we're seeing the bright
green cells are algae and the purplish
organisms are purple bacteria and it's
unusual to find these two organisms so
closely associated because they usually
reside in such different environments
the green algae prefer oxygen while the
purple bacteria avoid it and yet as we
we keep watching they seem to come
closer and closer together so as we go
back in time why are these two very
different organisms finding their way
nearer to each other well we'll return
to that but in the meantime let's take a
look at this strange s-shaped organism
in the middle of your screen scientists
have been arguing about what that
organism is since 1847
when a Danish scientist named eugenus
varing wandered along a beach and found
this organism in his samples some have
argued that it's a single organism a
flatulate of some kind others have
argued it's a bundle of bacteria either
way the organism was given the name
pelma the screen is getting bright right
now because James is shining a bright UV
light on the samples and as the view
recovers you'll see that the pelma has
fully devolved into a loose bundle of
threads this matches the conclusion that
scientists had come to as well that
pelma is a group of bacteria in its
normal form pelma is an aggregate of
s-shaped bacteria but the UV light James
shown on them blasted them apart so
while we settled one Mystery by watching
organisms fall apart let's return to
watching the unlikely Duo of purple
bacteria and green algae approach each
other except of course we're going back
in time so what we're really doing is
watching these organisms move back to
the original condition that defined them
to begin with but what was that
condition well it seems like they were
probably in some neatly arranged pattern
that intermingled their
populations but before we examine
exactly what that organized arrang m is
let's check out what looks like a much
less coordinated grouping these are
three ciliates called spods and they
really look like three water balloons
playing a very violent version of tug
OFW but they're actually doing something
kind of fluffly they're engaged in
conjugation which is a form of sexual
reproduction that ciliates can undergo
to produce Offspring the thing is
conjugation usually happens between two
organisms so you're probably wondering
why are there three spids involved in
this particular exchange are ciliate
conjugation thre sums a thing well we
wish we could tell you but we have no
idea Dr Hena estaban who James often
works with said she once saw three
sporum conjugating so this isn't the
only time something like this has been
observed between ciliates but it doesn't
seem to be a well documented Behavior so
we don't know why it happens or what's
going on with the individuals involved
James did check on the spod trio after
they were done and they seem to be doing
well which oddly brings us back to our
purple and green Duo because as we'll
see any second now that duo is actually
a trio though in a slightly different
form this isn't conjugation it's
endosymbiosis the new member of our
group is an organism called pseudois
tinu and its single celled body is host
to that crowd of green algae and purple
bacteria we were watching before at some
point the pseudo bisma died spilling its
smaller residence into the microcosmos
as we saw in the beginning of our video
while the pseudois is sadly still dead
the magic of video means that we were
able to resurrect it in a way reversing
its tragic fate if only through the
power of editing it isn't unusual to
find green algae like these living
inside of other organisms we've seen
relatives of this algae in ciliates like
parami bararia where they provide the
products of their photosynthesis to
their host in exchange for protection
from their
surroundings what is much less common
however is to find purple bacteria
symbiance and what is even less common
than that is to find a combination of
purple bacteria and green algae endos
symbiance in fact this might be the only
example we know of most of the Endo
symons are the purple bacteria which are
similar to purple sulfur bacteria except
for the sulfur part instead they seem to
have lost much of their ability to work
with sulfur perhaps because their host
provides many of the nutrients they need
in exchange for the metabolic talents
the purple bacteria have retained like
we said early on green algae like oxygen
and purple bacteria don't and while both
perform photosynthesis they rely on
different photosynthetic pigments which
in turn absorb light at different
wavelengths so imagining these two
organisms trying to make a home out of
the same host seems like watch ing a
battle between two deeply incompatible
roommates and yet they seem to do just
fine in some ways you could see where
this is a good deal for the host who now
has two organisms who can produce
nutrients under different conditions but
strangely despite the flexibility that
might suggest pseudo
bluerisu tends to dwell in primarily low
oxygen sediments the preferred habitat
hat of the purple bacteria scientists
are still understanding how this unusual
threesome works and how the presence of
these two different endos symbiots
shapes the behavior of their host we
envision it as something kind of like
kids yelling from the back of a minivan
shouting conflicting demands at their
parents who are in turn focused on the
actual schedule for the day perhaps it's
strange to contur upt that image in the
microcosmos but in our defense the
microcosmos manages to craft far more
unusual
[Music]
sites thank you for coming on this
journey with us as we explore the Unseen
World that surrounds us we'd also like
to thank each and every one of our
patrons some of their names are on the
screen right now and these are the
people that make this Channel and videos
like this possible and we are very
grateful if you'd like to become one of
you can go to patreon.com/crashcourse
[Music]
[Laughter]